[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by misha simpson aka
francesca who stars in the witcher
season two i have a warning here that if
you haven't watched the full season of
witcher season two come back after and
watch this interview we're gonna be
talking spoilers misha how you doing
today
yeah i'm really good thank you thanks
for having me
oh of course i'm so excited to talk to
you it's exciting you're this new
awesome character on this big show
um so i love about francesca is the look
she has as this elven leader um what was
it like for you wearing something like
with these elven ears and the
prosthetics and i'm assuming those are
contacts you have to wear too
oh yeah it was amazing it was just so
nice to be able to transform into
something completely different
um and yeah so got contact lenses i have
to do a few fittings for those um
and it's crazy with the contact lenses
is actually really hard to see
um everything's really blurry and then
especially when we're doing the night
shoots it's really hard to see people's
facial expressions and obviously a lot
of acting you're you're reacting to
what's being given to you so that was
definitely very challenging um and then
having them put in your eyes well i
didn't like that but uh you get you get
used to them
yeah i mean we wouldn't notice though
you do such a good job that it looks
like it's totally natural but i always
wonder like yeah contacts must be
uncomfortable for sure oh gosh yeah
yeah but it's interesting because
francesca has one of the most elaborate
costumes in the show do you think it
kind of is an advantage for you does it
make it easier for you to step into this
character of francesca
yeah definitely i feel like i feel like
as soon as because sometimes you know
you worry you're like you're on the way
there you're like i hope the day goes
well today i hope everything i've
prepared goes well
and you get a little panic but then as
soon as the costume comes on you've got
the hair and the makeup but i just
really really felt the part and i just
felt i felt like francesca and it helps
to step away from misha having
everything all there put on you
yeah and and you really do become the
part of francesca it's awesome and you
it's it's interesting too because
there is this iconic look of francesca
from the games in the the card game
gwent
now that's like a picture if you were to
google for just a lot of people like
because she has these hair buns now do
you think there's a chance she could
rock the hair buns in the future and
would you be down
yeah do you know what i would be down
rocking the hair buns i think they're
great so we'll just have to see what
they have in store
we'll have to speak to dad watson for
that
[Laughter]
yeah no i i think you were hoping that
and that that's exciting yeah let me be
down um
did you find a lot of yourself misha in
the character of francesca
um
again i think
it was really easy to empathize with
francesca because obviously it you know
is
obviously a lot of the things that they
they go through is real human
experiences um obviously it's very
extreme um but you can you can really
put yourself in in the shoes of the
character
um yeah so i i feel like on that on that
front we're different but i was able to
match myself with francesca and
emphasize with you know what she was
going through yeah and speaking of what
she was going through i mean like you're
talking about the extremes but also
like that must have been crazy for you
playing this like miraculous happy
moment of having this elephant child and
then it having it get murdered
was that insane emotionally for you did
you did you film those chronologically
like did you go from happy to sad or was
it kind of all over the place how did
you do that
well
you know we we did start off um episode
two that was in order but then when it
got to the birth scene and then and the
death of francesca's baby
that was filmed in the same day because
you know we were filming over over covid
and every time the time schedules are
all over the place so i i went through
extremes on that day i went from giving
birth to the child and like you know the
celebration
in fact it's possible i might have
filmed the death of the baby before the
birth so it was just all over the place
so emotionally yeah that was it was very
challenging and you know i had my music
playlist that would get me into certain
moods and the moves i'd need to be in um
i felt like a complete lunatic basically
yeah no i hope you released that music
the francesca playlist for spotify i
think everyone would love to hear
no but that that's really a tribute to
how good you are as an actress and how
you can do all these range of emotions
um but also speaking that just from a
viewer watching this character's art i
was shocked
when francesca we know she wants justice
horrible things happen to her but she
goes on this like killing spree of these
babies you know so yeah what was your
reaction as misha reading the script for
the first time when you saw him
well i i kind of i was alerted to the
fact that she goes on a baby killing
spree before so i was kind of prepared
um when i was told about that i was a
little bit shocked because i i was
trying to work out my head how it got
from there to there
um to the extremities um
and yeah when i read it it was pretty
shocking but i think as for me as an
actress um
it's it's great because you get to you
get to really play
and it's never a boring day so i was
actually i know it sounds a little bit
sick but i was actually quite excited
because it's so
it's just so crazy you just really get
to go through it and to think what she
would have had to go through gone
through to get to that point i find that
interesting to play with
yeah and i think for fans of the show
why they love francesca so much is that
we don't know what can happen with her
now this show is like anything's
possible with francesca so
how do you if you're going to predict
like
how do you feel she might be going
forward like do you think she's going to
be kind of on this revenge path like
maybe would you yeah yeah i feel like
now because of what she's done there's
no going back there really isn't i mean
she's killed so many babies um i mean
how that sits on you morally as well i i
don't know but i just think there's no
going back i don't really know what's
going to happen with francesca but she's
going to have to you know i guess it's
upwards from there she's got to keep
going
so as an actress though does that
seem more challenging for you to play
her next season where
like can you still find sympathy for do
you need to find sympathy for to keep
playing yeah like comfortably how do you
find that
um yeah i feel like even though she's
done such a horrific thing i do think
again i'll be able to sympathize with
her and i can see where she's coming
from not that if she asked me i probably
would have said don't kill the babies
but
um
yeah exactly but unfortunately she
didn't ask me she just did it so
um yeah i i definitely can empathize
with her i think for her she's gotten to
that point where she's fighting back
because
they haven't done that for so many years
her people they've you know they've been
pushed to the edge of the edge of the
world so i think she's had enough and
she's just like i'm gonna do to them
what they've done to us and and i think
that's it so i do get it from that point
of view even though it's very extreme
no that that makes sense and and that's
kind of a good tip for just actresses
and actors looking to see how they can
kind of approach a role like that um
now i have to ask because i'm a huge
nerd with the witcher games but have you
ever played any of the witcher video
games and do you game it all in general
yes so i actually did play um
it's a wild hunt three isn't it uh yes
yeah the witchery that one so my dad
actually is a fan of the game so
i had a little play at his house and i
really enjoyed it i actually haven't
played games for a while i used to my
favorite game was crash bandicoot so i
was one of those people
it's a great one my ultimate game yeah
so yeah it's been a while but yeah no i
loved i loved playing the game it was
nice to just oh that's the world
oh that's great to hear that makes me so
happy because i'm like super nerd that i
got a tattoo for the game witcher so
it's the whole sword
yeah
so
um that's cool to hear that um
so switching gears would be too i don't
think you know a lot of people aren't
going to know about you like if they've
seen for the first time in the witcher
is that you know you won britain's next
top model in 2009 so yes
that was a while ago so you were
originally modeling right and then did
you decide to switch to acting at some
point where you're always doing both
like how did they kind of come about
with the acting
yeah um so i think always since the kid
i've always wanted to act you know i was
always begging my mum to take me to
these little drama scores um
i watched fame and i was like i need to
be in a school like that i love it um
but yeah you know i i fell into
modelling after winning britain's next
top model um and i enjoyed the modeling
but the acting was always there so i've
been doing workshops since 2012 um
and then i just realized i wanted more
so then i went to drama school and
probably like 2016
and yeah then i transitioned into the
acting so i kind of had to put the
modeling on hold just i i had to make a
decision basically i had to turn down
jobs when i was in drama school as well
just because i was like my focus needs
to be here um and i'm glad that i did it
so um seems to be paying off so far
which is lovely
yeah hell yeah i mean and then storing a
role in this big show it's just gonna
send you to this next level which i'm
excited for you and thank you
in that excitement though i think what
fans like to see too is they get excited
they like seeing a new face they like
seeing someone so good at it and
they like seeing though and i say this
on my interviews like you're on social
media you show the passion for it you
know and that yeah you're excited um
yeah do you get goosebumps still when
you see like this poster come out with
you jennifer angela the three
like strong woman on this show like does
that make you you get the same feeling
we do as fans seeing that yeah yeah it's
just it's just mental every time an
image comes out of francesca or you know
anything to do the witch i'm just so
excited by it because it's it's you know
it's my it's my first big gig so i'm i'm
super proud um and i still can't believe
it when i see myself you know when i was
watching the series and you know seeing
these posters and i'm with these
characters that are already established
um it's just amazing yeah i'm like i'm
like shell shocked
yeah and
speaking of just like shell shock you
got to be shell-tracked too and feel
good like i when i always scour on the
witcher reddit and there was a post that
you know someone's asking a poll who's
your favorite new season two character
and if you go down it's just francesca
francesca francesco francesca all the
way down um and many a tribute though to
your performance of her so it's not just
oh we love this character like the
actors playing her how does that make
you feel seeing that
oh that's really lovely honestly um it
just it makes me feel really proud and
just
happy that that you know i was able to
police the fans as well and and yeah
it's just it's it's a nice confirmation
that i'm you know i'm doing a good job
so it's yeah it makes me feel really
really happy
yeah and you you crushed it you did a
great job and everyone should be excited
yeah i'm happy your character survived
too so we're going to see more
francesca's
yes i can't wait so everybody i mean if
you're watching this you probably saw
the season but tell your friends about
it watch it again with your season two
it's out on netflix watch misha kill it
as francesca misha thank you so much for
joining me and i hope to talk to you in
the future one day
thank you so much it's lovely to meet
you lovely to speak to you